the fifth amendment of the Constitution
of the United States of America says no
person shall be held to answer for a
capital or otherwise infamous crime
unless on a presentment or indictment of
a grand jury except in cases arising in
the land or naval forces or in the
militia when an actual service in time
of war or public danger nor shall any
person be subject for the same offense
to be twice put in jeopardy of life or
limb nor shall be compelled in any
criminal case to be a witness against
himself nor be deprived of life liberty
or property without due process of law
nor shall private property be taken for
public use without just compensation so
for me the Fifth Amendment is really the
Big Kahuna I have lived and worked in
many countries where the seizing of life
and liberty and property without due
process of law was an everyday event and
we fought that kind of tyranny in order
to establish this young upstart of a
country that we all treasure and this is
not an easy amendment to enforce and
it's one that really requires our
constant vigilance I mean we've seen in
times of challenge and war in this
country this amendment be compromised
from Japanese internment camps during
the war to the drone assassination of an
American citizen al-awlaki in Yemen in
2011 we see extrajudicial killings
happen with alarming regularity on the
streets of our country in
law-enforcement contexts and when I look
at extrajudicial killings in other parts
of the world and the ease with which
law-enforcement become judge and jury on
behalf of the citizens and take that
power over somebody's life and
liberty and property to themselves it's
it's a slippery slope and it's a slope
that always begins with some sense of
emergency some contingency situation
we're just now just this once just until
we resolve this emergency it's warranted
but it is exactly those instances that
we have these amendments for it's very
difficult to make the right decision in
moments of fear and that's why we did
the thinking in advance and when we look
at what we're called to protect in the
fifth amendment
it wasn't drafted with the intention
that manely be exercised when life on
the streets of the United States is
peaceful and tranquil there's no need to
protect an American citizen against
being murdered by their government when
things are peaceful and tranquil the
only need for that protection is in
times of great tension strife conflict
fear and threat and those are the times
when this amendment is most important
we're in one of those periods of our
history right now and I really believe
that it's the duty of every American to
honor the the beauty and power of that
amendment by being constantly vigilant
that we enforce it
[Music]
you